hey everybody and welcome to a twisted
wild ride with sto I got to tell you D
Snider of Twisted Sister Fame is one of
my favorite guests of all time this
guy's been wildly rich and then totally
broke and then wildly Rich again and he
is such an amazing character I mean the
personality on this guy is unbelievable
and you know what else is unbelievable
my bucket list special available
everywhere in the world on November 14th
I'm so excited about it it is the
gnarliest thing I've ever done and you
can get your tickets for the digital
worldwide Premiere right now at
sto.com that's a big deal I mean wow is
it messed up and uh dude this one is
just a classic waiting to happen so
let's get into
it we will will not waste your time here
um no time being wasted you kidding this
is like this is like a long time coming
are we you know yeah dude I feel like it
is are we going rolling here here okay
here we go we'll get this
started people of the Universe I bring
to you D
Snider long last at long last I've seen
the Twisted Sister t-shirts the Twisted
you're wearing
appreciate that and you know that play
you give us we did what was the karaoke
show the killer carry killer Cary I was
the I was the voice over I did the voice
that's right yeah it was your show and
here like so I've been doing voiceover
for 30 something years all kinds of
stuff but I got a game show Killer
Karaoke and the reviews are off the
chain they're saying it's the greatest
game show and in the history of game
shows and I'm going finally a Payday I'm
going to be the Bob bu Banks or whatever
of Killer Karaoke and he goes full paa
the next
year he doesn't want to scare the
Tarantulas I'm like what
what my shot man a
shot that is so hilarious so good and
true and they brought Mark McGrath and
Mark no problem with Mark but it just
didn't have it didn't have the steo
magic every action has a ripple effect
that dude that is just too much I forgot
all about that there was another time
too when you walk away from a his show
only steveo only
steveo I am not man enough I am not man
enough I would have stayed
forever um there was a time you reached
out on TW Twitter about something or
other I I can't remember we we had a
little interaction on I do remember yes
I don't remember what it was I remember
but I think I was reacting to your
T-shirt cuz you've been fairly open and
and you guys the jackass guys I mean oh
dude you made kids are back like our
second most downloaded song I mean after
use it for the opening and it wasn't
just like a taste it was like the whole
opening of of that of that I was that
the fourth one it was the third one
Jackass 3D Jack 3 that made up for all
the money
yes that you lost in Killer Karaoke the
kids are back yeah he made it right yeah
I wrote all songs so yeah so that was
good that was
good okay you know I get it you know
Peta whatever you got to do whatever you
got do he was he was just having some
realizations you going through some
changes at that point it was uh they
they had like the the snakes that they
were dunk in the ice water with the
people while they were swimming and and
I got a lot of backlash from that it's
like dude like like putting um snakes
that uh they weren't supposed to be in
water cold AR they but it was extra
cruel to put those snakes in ice water
and that was your first snakes are cold
blood and that was your first like on
camera project since getting sober right
it was my first TV gig my first ever
hosting gig and wow when you put it in
that perspective I I uh I'm torn between
feeling like I've got integrity and
feeling like an absolute idiot but uh no
you should Integrity first man Integrity
first I mean especially for you I mean
when you decide to have integrity that's
a thing that's that's like that's a big
deal you stand tall for something you
know sure not a shame no I just I'm just
like wow it's so that didn't work out so
so funny um okay so do you know that my
first concert was Twisted Sister I do
not did not know that where did you grow
up I I grew up in London England what
I'm talking about I don't know I looked
it up today it was the the come out and
play tour of
1986 you did two nights at Hammer Smith
odow and um I think I think it was a
Friday so whichever one was was a Friday
I was um playing with the skateboard in
in the backyard my dad came home from
work and he said hey what do you think
I'll take you to see Twisted Sister
tonight and I just lost my mind I
thought that was the coolest thing ever
but of course we didn't have tickets so
we we bought scalper tickets at the at
the Hammer Smith odion which put us you
know maybe like 10 rows back oh wa and
so like like 10 row back from the stage
and and and my dad had me hoisted up I'm
sitting on my dad's shoulders like just
rocking out to Twisted Sister and like
one of the ushers saw this little kid I
was 11 and and I'm he's I'm on my dad's
shoulders the Usher say come on come on
let me Usher you up to the front so the
the Usher took me up to and couple
notable things happened um the AJ perau
threw a drumstick my dad caught half of
it this other guy next to him caught the
other half and I've never seen my dad
more physically intimidating ever like
that that drumstick was going to be mine
and my dad just mused it and I had this
and it said AJ perau on the
drumstick and at one point point during
the concert uh like I reached up you
reached out like you slapped me a high
five from the stage for sure I see a 11y
old kid on his father's shoulders I'm
like cuz I'm already a dad at that point
so my kid is already four years old 5
years old so I'm I'm totally getting
like this this D young dad with his kid
bringing him to a show so that was
deliberate it was not an accident that
that high five that slap of the hands
was was just really it was I want you to
know that that was really special man
that's awesome changed the course of his
life it was it was I
mean Biff naked Canadian singer um I
don't still have and I curse myself name
Biff naked and she said I Spit on her in
Canada on concert to change her life
so I said I never really spit on purpose
I wasn't like that punk thing I thought
I just like you know like Let It Go and
just hit her and she said I'm baptized
by D SN saliva my course my life has
been changed wow yeah so you got the you
got the good one the hand
slap back then you had this this whole
deal you were sharpening your front
teeth I sharpened my teeth yeah and and
now like the [__] captain my wife said
you want oral fixation or oral sex
because one of them's got to
go I opted to continue having giving her
oral sex uh yeah my kids listening at
home all listening to your show they're
all grown now you know exactly what's
going on Mom and Dad have no secrets um
yeah so I I ca those teeth yeah yeah it
was Prett pretty you know vampirey yeah
it was I had this crazy idea to file my
front teeth down into fangs and um I did
it and it was in
1985 so really I really wish I'd done it
earlier in my career so I would have had
more time with them but by the time I
had to be 86 87 I the band and and um
you know and as it I'm already tired of
it cap them so I got these are caps
thank God and your teeth look nice well
thanks man that's why I brought you the
book between your glasses and your teeth
you look very
smart I figured you can read and and now
your your book is called frats yeah uh
help me understand why why why it's
called frats so I grew up in Suburbia on
Long Island New York it's a you know in
an environment where there were high
school fraternities
um people go High School fraternities
I've never heard of that and I thought
it was the way of the world turns out it
was just a small microcosm about five
towns that had it because they were
fraternities all fraternities are
chartered by the local police which
gives them a degree of legitimacy in the
eyes of the school uh they marched in
the parades Memorial Day you'd see the
fraternities marching but there were
just gangs walking around with colors
and uh this book is based on on actual
events and people go so were you one of
those frats no I was one of the guys
trying not to get my ass kicked by the
frats big weird dude I was like a Target
so but I just said when I found out as I
started touring people go I've never
heard of that I've never heard of that
and they were very violent um I said boy
what if you just arrived in that town
and like your senior year or I grew up
in the town I knew okay don't go down on
that street and stay away from that
candy store and those guys with those
black and red jackets they are evil you
know even as little kids you get your
ass k kicked and uh I said what if you
just rolled into the town knew school
didn't know the L of the land and and
and Bobby my Bobby Kovac he um sees
somebody who's being picked on and tries
to help him out for his day of school
and just crosses the wrong people and
his life spires spirals wildly out of
control so I just met with some people
today who want to make a movie out of it
which is pretty cool and just it's think
Outsiders in the 70s Suburbia in the70s
it's it's kind of from that place but
it's based on all true events and uh
it's intense now Outsiders was in the
70s no 50 50s 60s they were the greasers
yeah there was that crossover between
yeah they were they were still greasing
their hair Patrick swayy and Ralph
machio Pony Boy all those guys a lot I
mean uh Tom was in there Cruz was in
there I mean there was so many big stars
I think Kevin Bacon all these people
were in that movie it was it was an
early Copa film wow so maybe I'll get
that lucky unless somebody sees God
again and decides they can't make a
movie about high school violence because
it upset somebody on the
internet not naming
names
well oh my God so great what were you
gonna ask I I was going to ask when uh
so growing up your middle school and
high school days you sang in the choir
right oh yeah did I did yeah now did you
get picked on or judged by the so-called
frats or uh way not get your ass kicked
yeah I look I was smart and I was big so
um it was a you know but I was an
outcast I did not fit in with any group
I was just this weird dude and you know
when I was smart enough to stay away
from at the same time they weren't going
to go out of their way on the outside
chance that I was able to fight back cuz
that's not their thing they're not big
on people who can fight back they're big
on people who cannot fight back
which is the case in my book frats where
this you know little guy Brett he gets
picked on bad and and and Bobby comes to
his rescue uh you know to his detriment
ultimately but I finally crossed the
line so as so at first I was sort of
just sort like a background player you
know one of those like in life and
around 16 I said you know we're allowed
to curse right [__] this I'm tired of
being in the background not F I didn't
fit in just sort of this weird dude and
I even got I'm I'm you know I'm going
next level so I just seen Clockwork
Orange and I love that they wore Bowlers
so for some reason I thought this is a
good idea I'm going to start wearing a
bowler to high school well that that
pushed it over the edge for the frats
and a whole bunch of them jumped me and
you know and beat me up and took my my
damn bowler and then [__] was walking
around wearing it forever but uh but you
know but yeah so um I was you know I was
just um I was I was a nerd man I was
just you know comic book books but into
rock and roll and that was a that was a
weird thing is like when I got into like
became in the band and there's one
Easter egg and it's not about me even
though it's set in the high school I
grew up it's set in the year I grew up
in the town I grew up there's only one
nod at the prom this band dusk DUS us is
playing and they were the band in high
school in 73 that played all the dances
and Bobby says in the book yeah the
singer went on to become pretty famous
I was the lead singer in Dusk and that's
the only appearance I make in the book
you got bowler we're just reminding
people what a bowler is by bringing up
images on screen uh you know has the
bowler to the left yes to the left the
Round Top not the top hat which is the
sort of the straight up stove pipe one
straight up bowler right there what I'm
trying to figure out is why my guy Isaac
off camera up in the front didn't bring
up pictures of your filed front teeth
for I know you could see them when I
went to Washington to testify yeah they
were filed h d Snider definitely looked
smooth and sharp with his fangs but not
as sharp as the German engineered razors
from Harry's and not as smooth as I look
after I use my German engineered razors
from Harry's it's the best shaving
products man hands down no gimmicks no
stupid overpriced anything just quality
shaving products and that is what I've
been using for years and I'm never going
back and Harry's is ready to hook you up
with a killer deal because they've got
this starter kit which comes with the
weighted ergonomic handle the five blade
razor the travel cover which protects
the razors and the foaming shave gel
it's just a killer setup everything you
need a $13 value but they're giving it
to you for only three bucks this is a
deal that you need to jump on and and to
do that you go to harry's.com
sto it's the way to shave man it's the
only way I'll ever shave is with Harry's
so one more time to get this killer deal
go to harry's.com
steo and consider the subscription plan
to save time and money now let's get
back to it so you can see them when I'm
testifying and that yeah there was to
the left that one I believe that one
right there's got them matter of fact
yeah other words Getty Images are are
are over them but that's that's the
that's right there you know I I wanted
to to to say too that yeah top right
should have him as well come out Play
album let's see uh zoom in zoom in yeah
you can see him right there I'm just
Jesus yeah I'm just releasing I believe
like as this comes out
um my my third comedy special which I
taped in London England and and I told
my manager I said I've got this crazy
idea I want to tape it at Hammer Smith
odion where I went to see my first
concert and it was twisted sister and my
manager said oh man what if we reach out
and try and get Twisted Sister to open
for you at that at you know and and the
thing was the this the special that I
was taping there is this multimedia
thing which shows like shockingly
graphic footage and tri xx rated footage
and the hammer Odon just wasn't having
it so we couldn't we couldn't do it
there is it still a thing Hammer Smith
OD they changed the name of it oh they
did but still still a venue how long
were you living in England I was born in
England grew up in five different
countries lived in England from army
Brad or something yeah corporate Brad
corporate Brad N 9 years old to 12 years
old then I went to Canada for year and a
half came back 13 years through 18 years
old wow yeah so do you view it do you
have English citizenship I do because I
was born there and my mom was born in
Canada so I have Canadian citizenship
and my dad was born in America so I over
there doing the he was doing the
corporate thing yeah and lo and behold
they have a they have a little baby boy
I'm a triple National wow yeah and and I
do
identify you know I mean I'm going to
say I identify as British but I'm
profoundly grateful for the the
upbringing that I had in England it just
gave me a lot more freedom
than ative years why do you not and I'm
I'm I appreciate that you don't have an
English accent because some people just
go for a visit and come back like night
wait there a mon Cheers Cheers oh I
don't know how it happened I was just
hanging out with those Brits you
know I attended the American School in
London England okay so all of my
teachers and fellow students were mostly
American speaking my my family was as
well okay so you didn't pick it up I was
a skateboard order you know for most of
the time so now Twisted Sister's
popularity kind of started in Britain
correct yeah yeah well we were actually
we were regionally insanely popular in
the Northeast and I say insanely because
we were together about 10 years and we
were a phenomenon we would play a
thousand to 4,000 people a night five
nights a week wasn't that when you were
doing cover songs though yes covers and
slipping in Originals here and there and
every now and then we do like a a
theater show originals but um we were
and we were making bank uh the bands
like the really big bands there this is
I was just talking to I was talking to
Brett Michaels of poyson because they
had gone out to the West Coast and it
was a payto playay thing you know and we
were making thousands a night because we
could bring in thousands of people every
night so I when I was writing my Memoirs
shut up and give me the mic and they're
out there somewhere available I we were
at 1977 78 I was my early 20 of making
$1,000 cash a week I went online I did a
little you know what is that worth today
$350,000 a year so you had 20 something
guys rolling around the club scene
driving Mercedes not just and other
bands driving vets buying houses drugs
they were acting like they were real
rock stars playing cover songs and bars
and bars and had groupies you had
everything uh but Twisted after we
started making that money we realized
this is a velvet noose is the kind of
thing you think cuz we had we had to
have security it was crazy how popular
we were regionally without an album out
we gave a a free show but that shouldn't
undermine it uh they were doing a weekly
free show at an amusement park getting
300 to 500 people they did one twisted
23,000 people showed up and kiss was
playing to have a house at the Garden
that night so I don't even know what we
would would have done if kiss wasn't
took taking some of the extras but um we
just had this immense popularity but we
couldn't get signed so to your point
eventually after being rejected by every
American label like five times and
that's not an exaggeration we went to
England and got an independent deal uh
and we broke out of England and I
remember coming back to the States and
kids going where's your accent you know
you're I thought you were English
because they first heard about us in
Kang magazine and they bought the import
of Under the Blade on secret records
which came you know which came out of
England so yeah that was the breakout
but I just want to add that Hendrick
broke out of England Joan Jet broke out
of England Stray Cats broke out of
England a lot of bands have had to
resort to going there because it's such
a a small relatively small country but
such a force if you can make a noise
there the rest of the world pays
attention you know you'll set a trend
over there yeah yeah you had a British
record label but then in the States you
had your own record label initially we
had our we put out our own singles twist
Twisted was it twisted assisted records
I think so TS records put a couple
singles Sold 5 10,000 still could you
know couldn't impress the record
companies played The Palladium in New
York City 3500 people sold it out in
like two hours unsigned ban couldn't
couldn't impress the record companies
they were more interested in going down
to cbgbs and nothing against those bands
great bands there but they see a band
with you know 30 people in the house and
sign them while we're playing to 3,000
on Long Island over the bridge mhm and I
was like oh yeah it's Suburbia it was
discredited you know in a way it wasn't
like legit like New York City was and we
would never play New York City cu the
clubs were holes and they couldn't fit
our crowd we had so many people coming
to see us so you know ultimately we we
we went to secret records release and
that company folded like the minute the
album came out they went tits up uh and
we barely made it through a couple of
Strokes of luck which are unusual for
Twisted Sister and we got on Atlantic
Records and then we went from there did
you guys have a big payday or I guess
the bigger question is how did you guys
get a cameo in PeeWee
Herman you remember them in in the end
of PeeWee Herman that's where I was like
who the [__] was there a big pay or how
did you get into PeeWee
Herman I I think you saying we paid to
be on PeeWee Herman oh no no no no I
remember that scene I yeah no I was at
um MTV New Year's party
Peewee older listeners if there are any
hello is this thing on um well Peewee
was like a comedian he was on the
circuit and uh did had a comedy special
called peewee's Playhouse which became
the TV show but the original one he was
just this like eccentric you know
college crowd and I loved Peewee he's a
Groundlings guy yeah yeah yeah and uh we
were at that MTV New Year's party ran
into each other uh Mutual admiration
exchang phone numbers and I get a call
um when we were in going La uh we were
touring with maiden and this was like
when tours were tours and metal was
metal when you know you're like mid 80s
there was no distinction between hair
metal and true metal or whatever metal
it was so Twisted toured with Metallica
we toured with Saxon we toured with Iron
Maiden you know and nobody blinked it
was just we were a weird metal band and
we were doing five nights at long be
Jina sold out Iron Maiden special guest
Twisted Sister and I promise you 7:00
the place was packed it wasn't like
people rolling in just there to see
Maiden it was it was the two of us and
so we're going to be in town and pee
calls up and says hey man I'm doing a
movie I'm like god dude congrats you
know you want to do a cameo and he I got
this idea and he tells the whole idea
with the we you know doing a video and
he comes cruising through and blah blah
with Godzilla I said that sounds great
so you know what song we doing like
we're not going to take it I want to
rock and PeeWee to his credit goes no
man burn in hell I'm like yeah Peewee
peewee's metal and so uh yeah that was
the first exposure for a lot of people
yeah what year was that
1985 huh so was that the you were
playing Long Beach on the uh Iron Maiden
live after death album yeah the one they
recorded there on the five nights that
was the Power Slave tour yeah Power
slaves yeah wow yeah Eddie on a stick
called it had that gigantic well if you
went to saw it do Eddie was in every
show but now he was getting as his size
was growing so Al Eddie would pop up and
it was only half an Eddie he was
literally on like a you know like some
sort of a hydraulic machine but he came
up over the top with his arms it was it
was it was amazing tour but then by the
end of the 80s you would never see a
poison we toured a Metallica you know um
and you had Metallica open for you first
Club one of the first shows on the East
Coast with m St the whole OG was opening
for Twist's sister I remember when we
toured with her they said dude we opened
for you I'm like you did when he goes he
goes found Casino in New Jersey like oh
D I was in the back put my makeup on I
never saw any of the opening bands you
know I was too busy putting lipstick on
dud yeah but uh that was one of their
first one of their first shows and and
throughout all of this like crazy 80s
Heyday and everybody's just on drugs and
everything you were never like did you
never drink or do drugs just never drank
never did drugs um started having glass
of wine with dinner about 15 years ago
me and my wife but neither of us did um
you were pretty hooked on coffee though
right yeah it's a problem I I read that
you you almost got fired from
Ted to caffein yes I was called in I was
called in for a band meeting my first
band meeting I was pretty [__]
excited CU I was younger than the guys
in the band they were they were like a
few years older than me and there were
City guys from the Bronx from I was is
dork from Long Island I was so excited
to be in the band go to JJ French's
apartment you know I saw some hardcore
porn in his bedroom this woman with five
dicks I'm like oh man this is crazy I
never saw anything like that on Long
Island and uh and then they say oh D
yeah come on in we're we're having a
meeting and I realized the whole band is
sitting across from me and I'm facing
the band I'm like oh r r and they go
dude you got to cut back on the
caffeine C and I'm looking at literally
a guy who's going to AA meeting every
night other guy's got a freaking beer in
his hand it's only like 10: in the
morning someone else has white powder
underneath his nose I mean these are
these are guys hard drugs drinking
alcoholics and I said wait a
second my coffee drinking is bothering
your drug and alcohol use I and they
tell me if they would if I didn't just
cut back they were going to have to get
rid of me what kind of coffee I mean how
much how much coffee were you drinking
am I
worst three full pots so that's like 15
cups that's like a
[__] three and then plus they didn't
have Starbucks then I was I love the big
one go ahead that's what she said at uh
at Dunkin' Donuts so two of those a day
plus three full pots my wife said I'd be
sitting with my third or fourth cup of
coffee on the couch and just like like a
like a junkie with a needle hanging out
of his arm i' be sitting there never
spill a drop but just like noded out on
the with yeah I was I was it was a
problem I've cut back it's still it's
still my go-to but you know I mean now
now I've said in media people go you
this guy takes credit for everything
he's like Jean Simmons I say that I that
twist sister created speed medal and the
reason why I know this to be true is
because I told you we were vastly
popular in Northeast well all these
bands from bonjovi and Cinderella and po
poison to Overkill carnivore Anthrax
they all I mean Public Enemy Chuck D
said if there was no Twisted Sister we
there'd be no Public Enemy he says I
would go see twisted and that that [__]
you attitude that that up yours attitude
they had inspired me to put PE together
so but all these bands would come see us
and and I an Overkill documentary he
said we put Overkill together and
Twisted Sister played fast so we played
fast I didn't realize how fast we were
playing cuz I was so [__] wired that
I just kept telling the band faster F I
really was and just I played everything
on until years later I've heard tapes go
oh [__] yeah I was out of my mind on
caffeine caffeine and it's legal kids
yeah so when the when you get in front
of Congress like it it you caffeined out
of course I mean you were like the face
of heavy metal in in front of Congress
you know you don't have to be testifying
in front of Congress to be under a lot
of pressure and really stressed out and
that's why I'm glad this episode is
brought to you by better help because
speaking with a trusted certified
therapist online is the absolute
opposite of stressful it's actually the
best thing you can do for your mental
health I do it because I want to protect
my relationship with Lux and that's the
focus of therapy for me is just working
on keeping the path of my relationship
smooth and healthy and there's a lot of
things to talk to therapists about and I
believe that pretty much everybody's got
one of those things so go ahead and go
to betterhelp.com
steo to find yourself the perfect
therapist for you they've matched over 3
million people with therapists and by
using betterhelp.com /o that's better
[Music]
hp.com steo you get 10% off your first
month one more time that's
betterhelp.com
so that you can find your bright spot
this season with better help now let's
get back to it I remember and I remember
like you know you were shockingly
articulate and intelligent but is it
safe to say that you are an unlik
you know like why why wouldn't they have
Slayer or Blacky Lawless you know and
like like I never I understand what
you're saying if you had if they had
done their homework and gotten past the
picture and the popularity so we're one
of the biggest bands in the world we're
on the filthy 15 uh you know I mean God
bless Frank Zapp and John Den for for
standing tall when few would but they
weren't on the list so we were literal
targets so they figured oh this guy
looks like a complete
[__] you know or an incomplete [__]
which is even worse uh you know let's
get him but if they had just spent a
moment there was no social media they oh
[__] he's married he doesn't do drugs he
doesn't drink wait a second this is not
or if they look at the lyrics I use four
syllable lyrics and we're not going to
take it I mean nobody uses four you know
trit and jaded boring and confiscated I
mean that's not rock lyrics you know
that's the de ation of Independence for
God's
sakes and so they did not vet me and
they got what they they got what they
deserved if they had gotten a Vince Neil
if they had gotten now you know that's
who they wanted they want someone to get
on I
go thank you very much thank you very
much Mr SN yes we've heard
enough uh but yeah they did not and they
were stunned I'll tell you I went went
back there maybe 5 years ago with
Grammys on the hill Grammys on the hill
the the Grammy organization does more
than just do the Grammy Awards they they
fight for the rights of of of of singers
songwriters musicians not everybody's a
superstar some people are barely getting
by it's just like the Screen Actors gu
strike it's not about Tom Cruz and The
Rock it's about those actors who are
alternately working shifts as a waiter
when until they get another gig you know
they're trying to get them right their
ass covered so I went with gramys on the
hill I was there with Smokey Robinson I
was with um what's his name from The
Fast and Furious movies uh black dude no
no the black dude I'm yeah yeah yeah
yeah he's a singer apparently as well so
all these people up there when I walked
into the capital building what a
difference 30 years made the Senators
and congressmen were running out to
shake my hand from Pelosi to Kevin
McCarthy everybody wanted to shake the
Snider's hand that was not the case in
1985 I when I got home I had all little
pokes on me from with those 10-ft poles
were sticking me all day long they
couldn't get further away this time they
were like oh [__] we heard about this
guy let's be nice to him so he doesn't
[__] us up have you ran into Al Gore
since then never met him I I when we
talked that day never met Tipper never
met him and I'm always love saying you
know Tipper and him are divorced yeah
you know his kids have been not kids but
kids have been busted for possession my
kids have never been arrested for
anything and me and my wife you know 42
years later we still married so I mean
you know don't throw stones when you
live in a glass house you know so the
the agenda before Congress when you were
there was it was the pmrc the parents
music Resource Center and they wanted to
Label records as explicit well they want
what they really wanted they wanted like
a a a more a grander so to could speak
uh labeling system o for a cult V for
violence B for
beastality uh they wanted like real
specifics and when Frank and I Frank I
met Frank beforehand as you can see in
that picture there I did not unfor
unfortunately I never met John Denver I
would have loved to shake his hand
because he was most damaging you guys
saw me and said yeah rock on but John
was so mainstream with his Christmas
and he was just all American apple pie
and when he said I liken this to the
Nazi book burnings the senator freaked
because you know this guy was like legit
you know John Denver but when Frank and
I went there we were told here we are we
haven't even testified yet that they
negotiated the warning Parental Advisory
sticker as a compromise we said we
didn't even speak why are we here if
you've already agreed it was it was the
it was record industry if you've agreed
to cave in before we even had a chance
to to to to you know to fight back
what's the purpose so you know both of
us were very frustrated that no matter
what we did no matter what we said the
sticker was a done deal and you were
fighting against any kind of a
sticker yeah you know and and look at my
concern so see I've become this this
spokesperson for censorship and I get a
lot of [__] cuz people there were people
there okay I was just being was TMZ and
now it's on social media they uh they
about the political using your song yeah
and they they as they fire off a
shitload of questions and one of the
thing I talked about was I get asked a
lot like what's the biggest was what's
your biggest concern about censorship
today I said that people don't
understand what the First Amendment
really means it is not the Elon Musk
total Anarchy say anything you want to
say it was never intended to be that
first amendment is not about screaming
fire in a crowded movie theater and
causing a stampede where people could be
killed and injured that's not freedom of
speech that the freedom of speech is you
know speaking out speaking your mind
speak you know speaking fearlessly but
to say things that you know are lies
with deliberate intent to hurt people or
and that's goes for bullying that's not
freedom of speech you're on social media
and say Cindy sucked my [__] when she
didn't that's not freedom of speech you
know that's an outright lie your
intention is to cause this woman this
girl emotional harm so people that's my
biggest concern is and when I went there
I said you know I I wasn't about say
anything you want I was speaking two
things one more that it's a parents
responsibility to decide whether little
steo goes to see a Twisted Sister show
or not it's not the government job to to
do that and my other concern was that I
knew there' be people out there or
organizations that would use the sticker
to segregate the music and while people
love to say I knew what records to buy
well you couldn't buy them at certain
stores CU they wouldn't rack them other
stores wouldn't even carry them and you
didn't know that Best Buy and Warehouse
Walmart they were making record
companies create edited versions of the
albums so you went to buy album you went
to buy that kid rock album is the one
that he broke big on let's say with ball
with the ball and um and when you bought
it at Best Buy the song [__] off was not
on the record yeah so you didn't W but
you weren't it wasn't like edited
version you didn't know they sold it as
the version and why shouldn't a grown
man or woman and by grown I mean
teenagers you know be able to go and buy
the actual album not have it decided for
them yeah I'm with you dude Bravo to
everything that you've just said said I
loved all of that thank you and when I
was a kid the the the fact of it being
explicit and to this day I've always
understood that that just means that
this might be offensive to some people
but they've not changed the actual art
and furthermore them forcing the the
bands to include the full lyrics printed
out in the this album sleeves in the the
cassette sleeves like I loved that
because I wanted to know what they're
saying well Frank suggested that Frank
Zappa he suggested that and um and and
Al Gore said you know that might be a
solution to the pro you know and and
Senator Exxon and all these people U but
they never actually made that like you
know you required I always put the
lyrics in I wanted people to know what
I'm saying because sometimes it gets
Lost in Translation you know I was
thinking burn in hell there was plenty
of people who were going yeah we're burn
H but it was actually a Hellfire and
brimstone sermon actually a warning I
had you know it felt in my life I I was
raised a Christian and I felt in my life
like I had had some close calls with a
lot of things I was arrested a number of
times for violence and all kinds of
things like that and I said man I you
know ially went to prison for assault in
a road range incident that just
escalated and I wounded up you know
hitting this guy in the head with a tire
iron but it was with good reason but
anyway but I was like holy [__] you know
like that that Chi that went what was
that what was that from that movie
anchor man that got went out of control
quickly you know you know that was it
was like how did that happen you know
this dorky guy like beating this guy up
with a tire iron too much coffee it was
C it was coffee that was it too they
said as the judge said we're going to
let you go but you got to come back in
the caffine yeah your sentence you're
too on edge you make a good point that
clearly there weren't uh requirements to
include the lyrics uh because I had this
crazy encounter I went to a Cannibal
Corpse show right like I was brought to
one and then they ushered this before I
got Sober by the way they ushered me
into the dressing room of the band like
the moment they got off stage which is
typically the worst time to to mess with
with an artist right when they get off
stage I always try to give the band a
little space yeah so but they they bring
me right in they you know I hear that
the guy's covered in sweat you I'm
talking to the Cannibal Corpse guy and
he's you know reasonably like smiling
you know and meeting me which singer was
how long ago was this I'm this would
have been in definitely in 2007 2007 so
was corpse grinder probably big guy they
call him the neck his neck is like this
thing it's wider than his head yeah the
neck I say so I say to him I go man you
know I really really want to love you
guys man but I can't understand a
goddamn word you say and it makes me
feel excluded the neck I want to know
what's so you're saying that to this guy
after a show the lead thinker of
cannibal I want to know what's so evil
about what you're saying I can't
understand I feel exed and corpse
grinder and I did a duet on my last solo
album which was pretty cool he couldn't
believe I was because he's a fan he
couldn't believe that a classic rock
metal guy was was acknowledging that
what they do has value but I but of
course I do and uh and you know people
he was
but you know in honesty I was doing
radio at I've been doing radio for over
30 years and I had a metal show and I
got the first Cannibal Corpse record it
had the lyrics on it and it was talking
about [__] a a nun in the ass with a
knife and I was
like I'm out I'm out it wasn't f it
wasn't a fantasy thing like Iron Maiden
it was straight like talking about doing
it and but I wouldn't say they didn't
have the right to record those songs
you know I have the right not to buy the
record I have the right not to listen to
the music and you said you can't hear
the words anyway but now I speak kind of
I hate using the term cooking monster
but people use that term I understand it
better because my daughter just she said
dad you got to get like you know weight
the [__] up she's so hardcore so she
just keeps sending me these hardcore
playlist so now I I speak the language
fluently but yeah they are they they
have the but they go down you know they
go dark yeah it's evil ultimately wasn't
the uh the
uh parental advisory explicit sticker
like that boosted sales that's what they
say I don't know how since I know many
stores wouldn't carry the records but
there were plenty of people said you
know young people back then said they
looked for those stickers yeah you know
at the time so maybe it did maybe it
didn't you know I don't know what pissed
me off it went from being a sticker to
where they actually just made it part of
the printing of the cover so it was part
of the art it wasn't even something you
could peel off it was something like so
you did an artart design and then they
just Incorporated this sticker in there
H yeah well it's probably somebody's got
to put this stickers on there save a job
I I always thought it was cool I always
thought it was cool and um you know it's
interesting what you say about you know
the the just purely for the sake of
being shocking describing these horrible
acts of violence when you know I think
if Slayer was in front of Congress they
would have arguably been maybe not
equally but but very articulate made a
really strong point that angel of death
was not uh glorifying the Holocaust that
you know yes usually usually the bands
are I mean look we're not complete
idiots we're incomplete idiots no we
we're not complete idiots and and we
think about o lyrics and there a lot of
messages in there and Slayer I know
would say you know they the subject
matter is really intense
but it was it's not that they're
supporting endorsing whatever they're
reflecting on it Iron Maiden you know
the nightmare of 666 you know that that
it was this dream he had the first thing
he says he had this dream yeah you know
and about and and you know about about
the Satan coming for him so I mean you
know at the same time there have been
lyrics well one of the bands that was
was regaled at the time was the mentors
you remember the mentors I don't so the
mentors were this band got so much
publicity out of this the hearings they
wore hoods oh and they were uh is that
the mentors right there yeah okay
mentors the cu's clan no they weren't
white hoods they were terrible but and
the senators were reading their lyrics
and one of the and and and the people it
was this I'll make you sniff my anal
Vapor I'll use your face for toilet
paper and these lyrics and the other
senators are giggling and laughing
because it was a goof man it was a goof
and they but they were shining aot
Spotlight on it nobody even paid
attention to the mentors po they still
out there playing thanks for the pmrc
they're Legends now wow so to Scott's
point the they did sell more because of
it yeah I guess the mentors did yeah oh
man this is fantastic um with uh with
radio when when did you get into radio
so Twisted Sister
crashed and burned in ' 87 and
officially in ' 88 I I think it was
announced in in January of 88 I read oh
but you know what you're probably right
cuz it was like October November when uh
and and then before I officially
notified the band that I was out um of
the band and I guess that's when they
officially say you're correct I stand
corrected on Twisted Sister lore uh for
okay and um so then I did another band
called Desperado major deal you know big
money so much had you know clyve B from
Iron Maiden was playing drums and Bernie
touret had played with Ian Gillan and
Azie anyway and then that got sheld and
then the bottom started really falling
out the music scenes I did a b called
Widowmaker grunge came in and I like to
say that I received a uh telegram
telegram this telegram uh what you do we
don't do anymore stop uh don't bother
trying stop stop singing performing even
looking like you do stop um but that's
basically what happened with grunge and
I'm married I got three kids I can't
believe I made millions and I had blown
millions and I wasn't drunk and I wasn't
nobody stole it it just you don't people
say well how do you do that the ego that
got you there in the first place won't
allow you to accept it's over now was
this the time that you also declared
bankruptcy too twice twice Twice first
time was a was was a uh designer
bankruptcy with the top you know I
didn't lose anything but just a lot on
paper and the second one was me filling
out the bankruptcy form and going to
bankruptcy court and and and you know
and and and just I had I had a year in
the early 90s where I had zero dollars
income and is this is this true where
you were working a desk job answering
phones and people would recognize you
asking you aren't you D Snider and you
would have to lie yeah yeah I didn't
have to lie I just was so
embarrassed I was like nobody nobody was
interested in what I did it was like I
had studied a form of medicine that they
found a cure for so they no longer need
doctors and
handlers oh yes you specializing cancer
we got a pill for that
now child dysfunction I got to believe
that that even in the '90s that the the
we're not going to take it I want a rock
like you know gets baked into some huge
movie I'll tell you what movie that uh
road trip road trip that was one of the
first times it started showing back up
who doesn't love it when money just
shows up and that is exactly what
happens with draft King Sportsbook the
official betting partner of the UFC when
you download the draft King Sportsbook
app and use the promo code steo all
firsttime users will Instant L get
$200 in bonus bets as soon as they bet
just five bucks now if you're going to
gamble anyway then use draft King sports
book $200 and free bonus bets for
betting just five bucks you can't go
wrong and this weekend is UFC 295 Yuri
prosa against Alex Pereira for the
vacant light heavyweight belt the
heavyweights banging it out for the
interim title that's Tom asol against
Sergey pavlovic and when you're watching
the fights watch close because I'm going
to be right there by the Octagon I
wouldn't miss it for the world I'm in
Madison Square Gardens and wherever you
are if you want in on the action use
draft King sports book and again
download the app use the promo code steo
all firsttime users instantly get $200
in free bonus bets for betting just five
bus
gambling problem call 1800 Gambler or
visit www.1 1800 gambler. net in New
York call 8778 hope Andy or text hope
Andy to 467 369 in Connecticut help is
available for problem gambling call 888
78977 77 or visit ccpg dog please play
responsibly on behalf of booill Casino
and Resort KS 21 plus age varies by
jurisdiction void in Ontario bonus bets
expire 168 hours after issuance see
Sports book. draftkings.com MMA terms
for eligibility and deposit restrictions
terms and responsible gaming resources
have a great time we'll see you in
Madison Square Gardens now let's get
back to it I remember it was it was a
actually the first thing because it went
dead I mean this is a facts I mean you
obv did your homework I sold my catalog
voluntarily for a shitload of money okay
and for those trying to understand how
that works see when you're getting
royalty stream it's it's income so
you're taxed at a 50% rate if you sell
your catalog it's at a capital gains
rate of 15 to 20% so if you get the
right amount they call it a a multiple
so they say oh you're okay you're
pulling in uh a million dollars a year
on your catalog will give you X years in
advance you and your accountant look and
you go okay so I can have and I'm just
I'm just pulling numbers out of my ass
you don't know these are the real
numbers I can have $10 million now or I
can wait and at
20% and take that money and invest it
and you you know as or I can get it
hopefully every year because you never
know some years you're less some years
you're more for the next 10 years at
50% so I'm only getting $500,000 instead
of getting $800,000 you know you f88 m
you know it's I know there was you told
there be no
math but and you sit there you go okay
this is the point and you see so many
people this is where I sell and I do
that you know but to your point I was I
couldn't sell my catalog we were so the
grunge thing came in so hard the hair
metal was so out of Vogue nobody would
even buy it I would have given it away I
would have sold it for 10
$20,000 my songs I was broke I had three
children my wife God bless her you know
she did all hair makeup wardrobe uh the
bone logo she did all those things she
went and worked at a beauty parlor
started doing makeup for Bridezillas on
weekends and I I went had to got a job
answering phones at a desk I we only had
one car i' ride a bicycle there and
answer phones and people come in and
it's is that D Snider on the phone is
this 19
9192 and and you trying to tell them
that you're not D Snider you got your F
I think they were they even C by then
that was cuz that used to be tough to
say it wasn't him but nobody would
believe it now how long after that you
okay you declare bankruptcy all that you
sell your you sell your whole catalog
well that was
years now how around what time was it
you you created that Christmas song for
your wife and and and Seline Dion ended
up recording it yeah so somehow during
the 80s early 90s or whatever my wife
asked me to write late 80s I mean this
is like after the band's broken up and
you know she asked me to write her
Christmas song and I'm like babe I'm
trying to come back from you know I
really you want a Christmas song I said
that's not metal she goes you can write
you can do it you know you were
classically trained counter tener which
I was and uh you love Christmas which I
do and so she so I was working on some
songs and I got a wild idea for a song
and I wrote a Christmas song not a rock
song and I and I recorded it I couldn't
sing it it was just out of my range got
a a female vocalist Merry Christmas done
that was the end of it cut two I don't
know when it was late '90s not sure
exactly when it happened um yeah maybe
very ear yeah late '90s and I'm
still on the balls of my ass and uh I
get a call the engineer who was in the
studio recording that song with me is
now working with Selene Dion and he
tells me Selene Dion wants to record my
wife's Christmas
song and the first thing I said did you
tell her who wrote it and I said not yet
I said do not tell her Satan wrote a
Christmas song because I said just put
the [__] song on the record and keep
your mouth shot so um that record is the
biggest selling holiday album of all
time 14 million copies it's called These
are special times and um you own the
publishing to that yeah hell yeah and we
call it the house at St Selen and that's
even bigger than Mariah Care's um what's
the name of it that Christmas song that
she has I can't say that for a fact
certainly that was a hit song in of
itself this was on a hit holiday album
and then you know I remember Rosie o'
Donald sang it on the Christmas special
and I'm just sitting there just going I
can't believe this and and they don't
know who wrote it and then my wife's
crying it's so beautiful children are
singing it you know it's uh but anyway
yeah that's was the only only song I
never wrote for for commercial release
and it may be the most valuable song I
ever ever wrote wow crazy unbelievable
and then you get back together with
Twisted Sister and put out a twisted
Christmas right so Twisted
Sister I got mailbox money coming in
very nice and uh you know and and I
really I really wanted to fix it with
the guys I was a real [__] to them
really I just you know I I believe my
own hype I mean I nearly destroyed my
marriage amongst other things I
destroyed every relationship I had you
know at in the mid 80s I thought I was a
God you know and um you know and it just
made my band's life miserable and went
up quitting and all so I really wanted
to reason I wanted to reunite was to fix
it and it took a long time for the guys
believed I wasn't the same guy they kept
waiting for the other shoe to drop as
the saying goes you know they just you
know cuz couldn't believe I was so
different but I you know I had been
humbled you know um yeah you weren't
drunk and then got sober you're like
sober and you're still sober yeah but
when you're take riding that bicycle to
a desk job and you're out there you know
and you're just you recycling cans and
just just you just doing anything to
save money to feed your kids it just
said God you know was like those Lord if
you ever let me have success again I
won't be an [__] if I am you can smot
me strike me dead you know but everybody
I've met who is like he's bigger than
God if they like were humbled like
Stephen Tyler Errol Smith he was I saw
him at the bottom smacked out of his
brain living at that hotel where Sid
Vicious was at you know showing up to
borrow money from a a few bucks from my
manager I said he gave him like five
minutes he said we're going to bank I
have to meet somebody and he pulled like
five grand out of the back to get and
Stephen Tyler comes walking in like like
just you know he's skinny to begin with
but just [__] your heroin out and I'm
going you're giving him five grand and
my manager used to be a concert promoter
and said I made so much money off that
guy in concerts if he never pays me back
it doesn't matter I owe him that much
and you know hey man what's going on D
how you doing you know like that whole
you know the heroin thing did you did
you do heroin I was not a heroin guy but
so you KN heroin you you know heroin
guys I I was a big heroin guy yeah yeah
I mean you guys I mean when I see guys
who wrote books the heroin I'm sorry
they write books about being on heroin
the heroin guys I know they couldn't
find their dick let alone a pencil to
take notes come on man come
on it's either purely fictitious or you
aren't High you aren't High okay that's
it so anyway but by the way to uh for to
his credit Stephen Tyler pay my manager
back you know he came back and you know
and and you know and I've run into him
many many times and you know he's a
great guy he been through hell and he's
back and he appreciates it you know
Brian Johnson wasn't a heroin guy at all
but he had given up on rock and roll
given up he was working doing vinyl Tops
on cars in Wales where I think that's
where he was from Wales and he gets at a
left field he gets the call to audition
for ACDC and he knew the guys and he
knew guys well enough that he thought it
was a mercy audition like all right we
got to call Brian cuz he'll think we're
being you know like there were friends
enough and he went in he auditioned and
went back to the working putting vinyl
tops on he told me this story and then
you know and he says he gets a call hey
we're in the studio come on down he's
like you know they were friends so
thinking nothing he go out the studio he
walks in and anger says to him you're
never going to put another vinyl top on
a car
again so when Brian if you ever met
Brian Johnson the humblest most down the
Earth he was T he had given up on rock
and roll he gave up on his career you
know I mean he learn and and he was
rescued he was rescued you know and so
oh by the way he also told my manager
told me that basically Bon Scott picked
Brian my manager signed ACDC and uh he
said they were at a club and Bon comes
rolling up Brian's in a b called Jordy
back at that time with his arm around
Brian says anything happens to me this
is my replacement literally picked his
own dude so um and yeah I guess they B
took him seriously you know um the
singer of corn most humble Jonathan
Jonathan most humble best dude ever you
had him on the show right yeah yeah uh I
I wonder
like I mean he I mean he was like a you
know embalming bodies or whatever like
he he he had a life before rock and roll
yeah yeah it was a tough one too judging
by the lyrics of some of those songs I
remember that first album is Daddy it
was a daddy not to touch him or feat him
or whatever I I remember I was doing a
metal show at that time go holy crap
this is this is way too personal I think
that I mean I think what I'm what I'm
getting at and and and and but I totally
relate I think anybody who
becomes um any kind of a celebrity is
going to have Growing Pains you just
can't hand somebody that much resource
that much power and Prestige without
them well you know man everybody starts
yesing you to death yeah that's the big
thing everything you say is like gold
you [__] it's gold and just yes yes Ste
yes Steve yes you know and and my wife
was the only one who kept Brooklyn tough
Brooklyn mob princess she was like she
didn't change her you know she would
always say no to me and that's when we
nearly broke up cuz I was at a point in
my life and nobody says no to D Snider I
do whatever the [__] I want and I'm sure
you went there had a moment there as
well I I definitely had to fall on my
ass in a big way and uh I'm super great
grateful that I did yeah and I am too
yeah I am too because the trajectory I'm
on I would have been divorced we nearly
got divorced um I only had one son at
the time I wouldn't have the other
children I have today I wouldn't have
the life I wouldn't have my wife I
wouldn't have my I you know I needed to
be knocked down Peg you know um I needed
to be humbled and I was humbled and boy
you know it just you just again if you
ever let me please let me have some
success again I won't be a total [__]
you know and you learn if you don't you
are a fool so so back to radio did you
get into radio because of Howard Stern
Howard I owe Howard so
much he we connected at on a Letterman
show uh well that I stormed in so do you
know the story I don't it's it's worth
it's worth telling so um so I'm like
king of the world it's 84 Christmas I'm
uh in go taking my wife and son Rockstar
style to see the Rockefeller Center
Christmas tree what does that mean we
drive in a limousine we pull up
alongside it uh my wife and son get out
and go walk up the tree I roll down the
window and I stare through a crack at
the tree this is Rockstar style so and
so I'm looking at the tree and my driver
goes you know Howard Stern is I said no
he 84 doing afternoons on uh on R krock
I think just came back to the he goes I
DJ
I said yeah he goes he talk about how
ugly you are
today I said really he says yeah he's
going to be on the Letterman
tonight and I look and we are parked in
front of 30 Rock where Letterman was
filmed MH I said what time is it says
it's uh 5:00 that's when they film the
show so I said all right let's go give
Howard Stern a little taste of reality
so now this is pre 911 I just walk in
the front door and security said D I'm D
hair out to here and you know and I just
go straight up every hey D what's going
on I said where's our St they go I was
in the dressing room I kick open the
[__] door and he's in there with Fred
Jackie Robin and him the biggest dork I
ever saw I mean little clear glasses a
little afro some the
outside oh you got stop um yeah yeah
it's in the
window they're they they're they're har
harassing us about if we have a parking
pass over here
dog yeah I was hoping y to put us where
I can easily see it so I would have to
bother y thanks man miss y too yeah it a
supposed to be like that but it's all
right all right Co yeah we're we're
almost done I ain't going to switch yall
man I was hoping y'all had one I hate to
mess with this car right
here thank you for the respect um okay
so who's the dorest guy so yeah dor guy
cordoy pants and I kicked the door open
and I was like you and he sees like in
the afternoon he's talking about me on
the radio and I am there there like the
zooney fighting man if anybody remembers
that Karen blank and Trilogy of Terror I
charge in platform shoes up to Here Come
charging I Slam against the wall I'm
going to [__] kill you it's
like and then I just start laughing
because I wasn't I was only [__]
around I'm I don't give a [__] you know
what you say about me just you know
don't pronounce my name right you know
um and I saw he go you're not mad I said
no I'm not [__] mad I was just down
looking at the tree with my wife figured
I [__] with you so and we start talking
and we grew up in the town next to each
other both married both had a kid same
age we lived in a nor like and so we
exchanged numbers and um we become
friends so I start doing his show
regularly and Howard just is first
person that said this guy's got more Val
value well the Washington thing helped
people said this guy's kind of smart but
I'd be on a show regularly we' Cruise in
you know to the city together hang out
for four or five hours on the show head
back go back home together and um he
said you're awesome on the radio so he
started like pitching me to my to agents
he got me an agent over at Don buckwald
he would go in and he'd go to call radio
stations on my behalf take meetings on
my behalf to try and get me a gig and
then the bottom fell out of rock and
roll so I thank you know I mean he got
me into radio I started doing radio and
I mornings I've been doing radio for
over 30 years voiceover as well that all
came from the Howard Stern Show wow yeah
you did PlayStation voiceover too yeah I
was Jack and Daxter I was that was The
Wizard stay away from the dark ethos
yeah so I've I've done a lot of VO stuff
as well and I once almost had a game
show that I would have been was a would
have been cash money cash money for
years to come I was going to be Bob
Barker I was going to be one of those
guys the one of the voices one of the
voices and then the freaking host saw
God yeah H what's your relationship with
Howard like now so as many things
happened we drifted apart and really it
what happened was divorce so how and I
met and he was married I was married our
wives became friends our kids became
friends
we social as a couple and it was a great
thing when you're married to find
someone that you you get along with In
The Biz who also your wives get along
and your kids can hang you know you're
like this is cool and Howard got
divorced and he started he and when I
met him he wasn't getting high he wasn't
drinking wasn't doing drugs and then he
started he became single guy he's going
dude what going out we're going to strip
club I'm going dude I'm still married
I'm still the same guy I didn't you know
my life didn't change your life changed
and then he
met Beth Beth Beth I'm not trying to
just uh and and we one time susette Me
Howard uh and uh Beth hung out and
afterwards susette felt this
incredible uh disloyalty and if
anybody's everever dealt with been
friends with couples and a divorce
happens you always lose somebody in a
divorce you got to chew sides you got to
chew sides very tough to remain both and
Suzette just said I just felt
guilty the he say she was Beth was nice
enough nothing it was anything wrong
with Beth he says but I'm friends with
Allison it's like I'm cheating on her so
you know Howard's life went one way and
M went another but the truth is um he
continued on his trajectory and uh you
know he just became this thing I my life
you know I moved to Suburbia and and
raised my family yeah I was recognizing
myself but I learned how to just sort of
fit in I didn't want to not fit in I
didn't want to be not be able to go to
my kids' baseball games or football
games I just wanted to I wanted to you
know and I learned how to just like hey
how you doing shake hands sign an
autograph say you know I'll see you next
week when I come back to the next game
you know and I I I I'm happier as that
guy as my son once said famous enough to
get special treatment wherever we go not
so famous that we can't go anywhere oh
wow that's so well I said I said yeah
and that's a good good place to be
that's ex that's so well put and and I I
feel pretty pretty grateful to be about
at that level you know I get you're
pretty well known I get pretty special
treatment but like but can you go out
you hang I mean I don't have Paparazzi
chasing me around or any nonsense like
that the airport I mean I get through
the airport I mean I might get stopped
to take photos you know yeah I learned
now do you do anything to I don't want
to I don't want to like expose you uh
you understand what I mean by that um I
learned that I was creating half of the
cage I lived in the bubble so I'm
walking around with my hair scraping the
walls 6-inch platform shoes Jack is
sister I had this black bodyguard
driving around limousines why are they
looking at me everybody's staring at me
like God like I'm like they like hiding
and I said I'm I'm bringing the circus
of course people are looking at the
circus so then I started just put on a
base B hat and just a pair of sneakers
take off the damn Twisted Sister jacket
and I travel on my own and I you know
and and I go out with my family and
people say Hey you say how you doing man
nice to meet you I'm with the fam oh
cool cool no one ever gives me you know
everybody they they respect you and you
just you know go through life with a
simple hello and a handshake one thing I
don't do is the photos cuz that starts
to become a chain especially if you're
in a crowded area chain reaction when
you get to the end they don't know who
you are they just getting some I saw
everybody else was online so you know so
I learned that if you start but I always
say hello I always you know she talk to
him for a second but yeah I learned how
to function in a much much happier being
a functioning human being than being
hiding all the time and you had to get
to a point where I mean you were you
were a thing man I yeah I well thanks
man and expect you to be nuts I I sure
try my ass off to be a thing okay how is
that for a thing okay so Billy Joel once
said to me part of the problem is they
meet you they know everything about you
you know nothing about them he says
there's this
imbalance it's not anybody's fault it
just is so and you're kind of in this
thing like hey you know you're steo yeah
how you doing nice to meet you you know
and then there's this sort of pregnant
pause where they're waiting for you to
be D Snider waiting for you to be sto
they know you for a thing and and and
you know and it's just it's an imbalance
so that's a tough thing to get people to
do you feel like you went through a
thing where people expected you to act
out and you did it's it's not that so
much but I think what you're describing
is what has made uh meet and meet and
greets like like kind kind of like
uncomfortable on some level you know
like the idea of somebody like paying a
a dollar amount to have this experience
where they meet you and get their photo
with you it uh you you want it if you're
going to do it you want to give them a
great experience that they feel is worth
it but at the same time there's just no
way because it's it's just inher can't
live up to that it's inherently awkward
and odd and that's why I look at all the
the uh ComicCon kind of like you know I
just came back from New York ComicCon
appearances is what I probably the only
thing I do now I don't perform anymore
occasion I'll get up to an All-Star
thing uh but you know and and you know
and people it's weird I always keep the
guy with the cash register far away from
me because it's I'm so uncomfortable
with the idea that people are paying and
no one's well they say are saying they
have to you're being paid to appear so
like I like those ones better like I do
car Autorama have you ever done ever
aama if you ever get them they're great
they pay you to appear and then you just
sign autographs for free yeah okay which
is you know which is cool cuz they're
the ones you know they're using you the
the the events using you to bring people
in their event so they should be paying
you not the fans but yeah it is awkward
it's an awward thing small talk to 200
people gets a little tough small talk
yeah yeah and everyone you're on you got
to be on during that you want to give
them a moment so I always talk to them
I'm always you know and making you know
making the faces and and acting out and
not insanely fortunately people have
learned well you know he's reasonably
intelligent but still you want him to
have a moment with you especially when
they paying money for it and it's like
by the end of it you're like you know
whole day or three days it's exhausting
people go really it's exhausting yeah we
want to you to have a moment so we're
really that's not how we act at home I'm
pointing steo we I get home pretty much
just veg on the couch you know I'm not
like making faces to my wife it's the
last thing she wants is me going
she's like oh please seriously shut the
[__] up you know I don't want to you
know what I think no I don't want to
know what you think I don't know what
you think I've heard what you think for
the last 47 years tell them what you
think okay I I want to know what's going
on with that that car you drove up the
rat rod yeah um I always wanted a rat
rod and um I love Hot Rods I love muscle
cars and I saw this I'm not I'm I'm I'm
a Motorhead but I'm not a wrench you
know know I was the guy who tried to
work on the cars but my friends would
come over and they're waiting for me to
finish up my car and they're standing
there going dude give us the wrench we
got to go and they okay and they would
finish you know adjusting the carburetor
or doing the brakes so I never really
got good at wrenching but I always I
love Rat Rods cuz the spirit of a rat
rod I mean I think you know if people
who don't know it's kind of they're hot
rods and rat rods Rat Rods is what do we
got in the garage let's make a far out
of it you know we got a motor and we got
some rims and we got a body okay uh we
need a steering wheel we'll fabricate
that and and what are we going to use
for the frame we'll use these shock
absorbers and it's just this amalgam of
pieces and hopefully you put them
together and it just looks cool and
crazy and I found this online and I'm
like I got I'm living out right on the
PCH I live just off the pch in La now
right along I I had a beautiful drive
here I drove I overshot by the way I
thought you were down the road saw yeah
go by I flew by I go wait a minute I
came to my GPS I couldn't follow in the
car and uh you know and I said go this
is this is California it's got a 49 409
the beach boy sang about 409 409 that's
what it's got 32 rat you know Rat Rod so
and and and nobody can see me in it so
it gets huge attention but the roof is
so low nobody sees me but it's amazing I
can barely see them the cameras and the
reaction cuz it's it's the circus showed
up you know yeah so it's so much fun and
I just drive it around you know around
locally are you listening to the music
in there can't hear [__] in there can't
hear
[__] I was with a friend today and this
is great what it's all motor you know
there's no insulation it's loud as [__]
but that is the music that's the music
funny I remember uh one time going to
the airport I'm looking at these
pictures up here with the the the wild
boys guys yeah we're driving along and I
look out the window going down like
maybe the 405 or something look out the
window and I see Carrie King from Slayer
driving a PT
Cruiser just mean like we were like
we're both like we're all looking out
the window like oh oh my God scary King
and he just like turned and mean mugged
us and uh I'm met him and his wife um a
number of years later and and and
brought it up and they were like oh yeah
that was a loner like his car was like
in the shop or something I'm very like
clo cars are your street your street
clothes so it's very important to be be
seen the right thing and my wife drives
a a very nice BMW Z4 but it's small and
she had pink and silver pin striping
done other counts Customs guys did it
and so there's a lot of pink on the car
and so occasionally she's driving not my
rat rod but I've got a custom painted uh
uh Tesla S and I also have I got one of
the new Hummer electric Hummers wow
10,000 lb 0 to 60 in 3 seconds it is
insane it's a monster with the Hummer
the Hummer the new Hummer electric and
375 mil on a
charge it's just insane but I'll be in
her car and people like yo dear it's not
my car car I that's not my I got to
defend myself that I got to be in a car
that doesn't embarrass me so so selling
your music really worked well for you
yeah yeah St Seline and St SEL and St
Seline and you know and I've been doing
radio and TV and movies and and I wrote
book frats available uh but I've just
been doing a lot of different things and
exploring different things and and I've
been blessed with a second life you know
voice over uh that's been great as well
so yeah I I I I'm in semi-retirement now
I just I don't have to work and then my
wife got rich oh that became accidental
I met her her dad was a struggling you
know contractor mafioso uh yeah yeah no
he wasn't Mafia but her family is yeah
she he's he's not Vinnie's not in the
mob our buildings were all legit but he
um he built up his buildings and um he
left them to his kids
and all free and clear and just just
tens of millions of dollars worth of
property and they left it to three
surviving kids so turned out my wife is
Rich too so uh so you know life is good
and she's beautiful that's her right
there bottom right there she's laughing
yeah W she's doing yeah she's she's on
every top Rockstar wies list at number
one on many of them and I'm really she's
just this hot Brooklyn Italian chick you
know the other guys like they've got
models and ex Playmates and and she's
just you know just a girl from Brooklyn
you know uh who did and W up doing all
the costumes and hair and makeup she did
all those things for me as well so she's
just the total package my my my my
fiance is a production designer and
wardrobe specialist and she does all all
my stuff too yeah okay now you sell your
your music catalog and then I see you on
TMZ saying that you give the both sides
of the the political aisle permission to
use your music but it's not even
your
like no no well first of all first of
all um I don't not giving because people
but
everybody as far as licensing goes they
okay let me let me explain uh when
people use a song in any event that's
just um they call it seesack they call
it ASCAP it's ambient music they just
pay like a fee a general fee so whether
it's a Yankee Stadium or if it's any
sporting event or at any uh political
rally as long as they pay there it's a
very minimal fee they they don't need
permission it's just they just do it but
everybody loves the author of the song
to give it their blessing and they don't
like you to denounce it and I and so uh
it like there was a case in Australia
where a politician decided he was using
we're not going to take it for a
commercial campaign without paying he
was sued I was went to I went to court
and he lost and I have I have interest
in these songs by the way and also after
well after 35 years you get your catalog
back so my kids will get the if there's
any value they'll get it back and now
it's probably about 25 years till
they'll get it back so you know so I I
wanted to so I went up against this guy
and we won he had to pay and he it was
um but that you can't stop anybody from
just using the song as long as it's not
for commercial use it's ambient use but
they hate when I denounce them right
it's just you know they want you to
support them because you hear about like
I want to say Eminem or you know any
number of other artists like filing
cease and desists to people who are
using their their music but that's when
it's not chent that's when it's baked
into like a campaign video or something
yeah and the season theist is is kind of
like a a fancy way of denouncing um I
mean they really can't stop them um I
believe Trump um has knows this full
well because he's been asked to stop a
number of songs and he knows he doesn't
have to I asked him to stop he's wear
going take it and I'm give them you know
we do not see eye to eye politically we
were friends before the whole political
thing I was on Celebrity Apprentice for
three seasons uh hung with him hung with
his family had great times great
memories never got into politics because
that's or that's kind of used to be way
it was you didn't talk about that [__]
when you were just going having dinner
or hanging out did a lot of charity work
together um for kids cancer and all
kinds of things you know and when he
started running he said hey I want to
use R going take it I was like yeah go
go crazy man raise hell and then I found
out what he stood for and after a few
months U my kids were going you got to
denounce them you got to make him ceas I
said let me ask tell you something kids
and I kids are grown I said most people
don't even bother to ask permission you
know they just do it he asked permission
I gave my permission I said if I'm going
to stop him I'm going to give him the
respect that he showed me and I'm going
to pick up a phone I'm going to say
listen I need you to stop using the song
we're not on the same page that's what I
did we're not on the same page and um we
don't see eye to eye and and and what
and and he's to his credit he said okay
stop using it that night never use it
again and he knows he could use it uh
but he in but it just that was he was
and I called him back I saidy are we
cool and he said D we've done so much
charity work together and we had many
things he goes of course we're cool you
know and uh but yeah I'm I'm really I'm
anti-trump what he stands for I actually
don't believe that he I believe he's a
Salesman and he's looking for uh someone
to buy his product and the people he
found to who bought his product were
people I don't agree with and he takes
the position that he agrees with them
but I knew him before Howard St talked
about this endless at length yeah he
never showed any evidence of being
Evangelical being against women's right
to choose being he's a New York guy it
was never shown any of those thing I'm
just telling your people I know people
out there screaming I went political
here just saying there was never any
evidence of these things and I firmly
believe it's like hey look I'm selling
Trump as a product these people are the
ones who are buying it you know I used
to have a saying I used to on radio he
say you like me I like you that used to
be my saying he was that simple you know
you don't like me we got a problem you
know but uh you know and uh yeah that's
kind of like Bob Dylan Like Robert
Zimmerman's his name like he created
this character to sell music the product
to hippies and he started blowing up but
he wasn't really is that really I I've
watched a few documentaries on him I
never got that impression oh really I
that it was a that it was a fake thing
but he's got a sort of a it's
interesting to watch about him because
he sort of had a transition where he
came disappeared for a while and came
back at the from the crossroads you know
and uh you know and he had figured out
how to plug into the ZET Guist I think
we can say pretty safely that to date
still
Trump's not really showing any signs of
being very
Evangelical yeah I'm not buying it I'm
not buying it like I said I and you know
and it's just and and the fact that
there are people who are supporters of
his who are anti-semites and his
daughter is a convert she's Jewish his
son-in-law is Jewish I know he's not
anti-semitic I know he's not racist I've
been on the shows with him and we' done
so many things and you know so and but
he's affiliating with a lot of people
who are
pretty extreme in that regard you know
and uh but that's the sell his product
that's how I view it that's how I view
it and and I can't stand with him as
long as he's going to stand with those
people I respect that man and and I I I
appreciate the clarity too that it's
just your uh endorsement that that
you're W
withholding yeah people and people out
there they think we have this control
which we don't even if we have the
catalog
if they're just using it playing at an
events or something like that there's
nothing you can do about it right it's
crazy we watch UFC fights all the time
and it blows me away the the music that
these Fighters are allowed to pick to
walk out to they can they can walk out
to just about anything and I asked Dana
White the president I was like man like
what do you guys pay for music he's like
oh we don't pay [__] it's ambient they
don't pay [__] yeah I remember so one of
the first so Twisted in the
toilet you know
uh metal hair metal in the toilet early
'90s I'm going to balls my ass and one
of the first people to pick up on the
song and this is I'm thinking
'92 is the New York Yankees the New York
Yankees they are at the bottom of the
the they they're George Stein brener
they are just as low as he can be and
they start playing we're not going to
take it Jord George Stein brener heard
the song and starts playing it every
game and they invite me down to to a
game and it's the first time that
somebody used the song you know what I
mean and so they're playing it every
game at the end of every game you hear
it on TV it's it's so it's on TV I'm
hearing on TV so I I write I said hey I
call the you know performing right I
said how' you get extra money go we send
you a form fill it out explain your
special circumstances and we do give a
more money great so it was like pages I
fill out all these documents I my
evidence recording
$372
$372 yeah I said I just did all that
work for
$372 special dispensation $372 so yeah
they play them at these events and you
get nothing but what about the movie
Road Trip where they really crank she a
spike in your bank account on that well
that was okay okay all right boys get
ready so
now licensing becomes a thing I remember
the first license that we got that was
for like a cold medicine or something
so like and it was like six figures I'm
like holy crap oh I me I'm broke and I'm
the songwriter I'm like this is like
gamechanging now you know what I mean so
now we start getting offers and and the
music's coming back in the Vogue and you
get call and you get like a road trip
awesome young hip movie I remember going
to the theater that moment in the song
comes Rock I want a rock comes on and
they're just banging you're going You're
Going wow this is awesome never imagined
it so you you're praying for these
things I get a call from my manager he's
like we've got a licensing offer
major I said awesome how much he said
it's like
$300,000 I'm like wow got two kids in
college now I'm like yes I'm the sole
songwriter oh my God have not sold my
catalog at this point I go what is it
for he says it's for a women's
premenopausal
medication
I'm getting I'm getting douche chills
right now I'm going I remember I
remember it I'm like oh see dude come on
a woman's premenopausal
medication this is my legacy man he goes
D it's 300 GES I'm like what ises it
what does it do goes well helps with hot
flashes thinning hair stops vaginal
dryness wait a second
did you say it stops vaginal shyness is
this the truth he goes yes I go well
then I'm doing God's
work I mean who isn't against vaginal
dryness everybody is against vaginal
dryness yeah course I endorse
it give me the
money I love it no one wants a dry vge
that's
amazing that's good oh AB that was a
conversation I swear that was a
conversation what does it do that is
that i' I've spoke done like keynote
speaking where I've told people about
you know selling out find your vaginal
dryness and sell your soul you know that
is [__] fantastic dude what I I I
don't even know that I have any where do
you go from where do you go from from VD
vaginal I'll tell you where we go we go
to the goddamn bookstore and we buy
frats check it out I promise I've been
giving money back guarantee if you buy
frats um and you do not like it if you
see me on the streets come up to me and
I will give you your money back of
course I mean I'm around you know I'm
not all over the world but if I do walk
the streets and I'll give you your money
back that's my guarantee but um hey look
my best review was my wife been with her
47 years she goes it's really good I was
like what was that she said it books
really good I'm like you like it she
says don't push
it I've given you enough compliments in
47 years I'm not blowing more smoke but
it's really good and today I just was
with I tell you um can't say which one a
major Studio wants to turn it into a
movie cool so um you know it's kind
again Outsiders for the 70s in Suburbia
gang violence um it's you know really
it's it's you don't think it would going
on there in you know middle America but
there it is and they can get it at
Amazon Target everywhere they sell BS
yeah yeah yeah if they don't they should
have it if they don't have it tell them
I want these book yeah you know and uh
make them order it I love it man bro
this has been more fun than I could have
possibly anticipated likewise actually I
anticipated be fun see your thing your
thing is your fun yeah but that's to see
all that pressure now you got to be fun
I mean dude I I loved it I love you
thanks man thank you for everything bro
and thank you for all the love you've
shown me and my band over the years even
wasn't cool to show it you were there so
thank you in the jacket for sure nice to
meet you hey pleasure man all right
there you have it folks I stand by my
words that I enjoyed that more than I've
enjoyed an episode in some time I just
respect the guy I actually shot him a
text two days later saying hey this is
just an appreciation text cuz I just
want you to know that like the that your
words of accountability and humility um
you know just meant a lot that's the
stuff Integrity is made of and he got
right back to me said oh that's very
kind of you thank you and uh you know I
I mean every word of it dude I really
really like that guy and you know I
really really like you too and I want my
street team people to know that uh it's
only going to work the the promo code
Street team for the bucket list special
like when it's still in pre-order once
it goes live I think we're canning the
the whole discount promo code thing so
jump on that promo carde it's 20% off
The Bucket List special and be there for
the actual moment Premiere you know
you'll have the streaming for 30 days
after that but it's after the premiere
that I'm actually doing the live Q&A and
stuff so yeah we'll see you guys all
there I love you so much it's an
exciting time and [__]
yeah it's 20% yeah oh it's
25% oh that's right it's 25% for the
street team it's only 20 for all the
other ones it's because I love you
guys cool